going bearish my name welcome back to
another episode of cry of Peter
alright we're gonna go in here in the
last episode we did some hardcore
parkour there was a chainsaw guy chasing
us if flash um aids our titties and yeah
I think that's pretty much it
ooh here we go with the Silent Hill
remove it again sometimes in life when
you walk the streets to come to realize
you're in front of assess did you say
hello to Santa Laura hello Sonora
punching one time with a baton then you
start running why you will never know
but are deadly and swearing to you
something
the my team in my team policeman
academia book out there nothing to keep
the language hello your name a company
alright
I'm so sorry about you yes oh wow this
is really funny it's like sweetie shops
this is where you buy pills and stuff
give me my drugs
I need my drugs alright so watch house I
don't know if earlier advances but we
aren't stuck on that's for sure and that
lady just knows how to promote those
thingies that she's holding talking so
we need to find a fuse it looks like we
can go in here perhaps that big epic
indeed alright there's just my hometown
that is my crib we're just getting what
is that Glock BP 70 why is it BP 70
I actually know where it is I missed it
in the last episode maybe we can find it
again
who knows that's the fun of not finding
things
this unless with stone I still can make
this glass diamond Skippy
very nice very lovely definitely big
eNOS
that's not drugs to Japan women organic
Ciara Ulis alright so I don't see
anything spooky about this is just
lovely lovely lovely lovely lovely
I enjoyed this taking photos uploading
on pictures save Facebook so this is AG
like a school or something I don't know
what is this door won't budge [ __ ] of
course not it will never budge for my
butt oh come on baby it's really looks
like my custom school you started in
Stockholm
so maybe digit it knows ah there we go
found the die alright Sam hello that's
the point of this really weird really
weird I can't even walk between them
dime no not dying day later
alright we got something here a
screwdriver for what we can use the
screwdriver mom will never know but it's
about for us to find out stole god damn
this place has a lot of stuff this is
way too rusty to use as a weapon did you
see anything in back I don't remember
maybe over here [ __ ] this is really
weird
there's a totally crazy and weird let's
go in here
all right this is totally we're gonna
use it ah found it pretty good
oh [ __ ] are you oh I don't have saw that
coming
I should totally my goats should have
sound that coming oh I don't see you in
a couple of minutes when I get to fuse
again and punch the lady son of a penis
oh excuse me just go to in life
sometimes and you send the mail my
mailbox I wonder if I can make something
police babe lovely weather we're having
today taking photos
keep taking photos Darla swing for the
Appetit I get my friend a tricky board
another an F Nelson favorite give me go
in here won't budge I guess I'll really
[Music]
my talk why then is baton work I just
kept taking photos away so silly
sometimes
[Music]
I got my nails freakin Naples
alright here we are once again it is
time to take the fuse but first gonna
load this shotgun right in that [ __ ]
face
bring it oh [ __ ] oh I probably meant to
shoot him should have had the phone okay
okay start to my goats okay alright
bring it back thank you you're a piece
of [ __ ] seriously alright I wish I could
call my mom right now
mom if you hear this take me out of here
please
all right
all right we can do this
bring it [ __ ] boom
[ __ ] you put on a son of a [ __ ] son of
a [ __ ] I don't know why I said son of a
[ __ ] but I said it and then you liked
it a little bit it's hard on your facial
[Music]
expression bring bet bank match all
right gotta reload that [ __ ] got a
reloaded good get rid of the good buddy
all right
soon Rudy just everywhere bring it why
does freaking no no no no no back off
[ __ ] you little [ __ ] guard I had yeah
there we go
save it there save it there of shape you
all right lovely
alright time to reload
don't wait a pity no I mean everything's
gonna be alright
everyone's gonna be alright why don't
you real of the gun when I tell you
woman even though you're not a woman
here again but you could be I've seen a
lot of guns that are women
all right da da da da gotta go out so go
ahead
okay friggin shut up stop [ __ ] hate
you but don't use your magic tricks on
me lady girl I don't wish to plant how
you're doing where the [ __ ] am I
supposed to go and where's my lunch
alright why the hell was I I don't even
remember I'm so lost
why am I always okay they blitz all oh
yeah I'll take fun alright it's okay its
okay its okay its okay its okay its okay
its okay its okay its okay its okay okay
okay it's totally fine that's totally
cold Bam Bam Bam Bam
I am I am I am I am there we go gotta
say bad when you shoot otherwise don't
stop bad your little [ __ ] polish and
I'm sick of your [ __ ] ah I can do this
for Sparta Lady Gaga Lady Gaga alright
can read my can't read my no you can
read
oh the face she's got me like nobody
can't read my can't read my no you can
read my Oh page [ __ ]
my ex is not working when you [ __ ]
need it carry my kerima
Oh
Barney up-up-up poker face but poker
face exit there we go
but bucka bucka bucka bucka bucka poker
for you why is the exit when you need it
since the exit is what I'm so confused
what the hell that come from here I
don't even know anymore
send ready guess every way [ __ ] me
I'm so screwed I'm so scared I'm so
scared I'm so scared
maybe if we put it back they will be
like oh it's cold
we like you now you took a screwdriver
birthday you took it you [ __ ] take it
oh I don't even have it anymore well
that makes me [ __ ] doesn't it come on
baby
what I open the door and then I exit
what why would he do that
what am I supposed to go fire
extinguisher
someone please what am I no goddamn
Ramsay Lady gaga
energy generation everyone at Britney
Spears Britney Spears great miss Pierce
what's the point of this place I don't
get it I'm just [ __ ] me just do it right
now
don't do it I was kidding I'm just
saying nothing
seriously why do I accent donde esta la
sexy kato's No
shouldn't they be marked on the thing No
holy [ __ ] look at my health it's crazy
and my stamina yes okay there we go
finally holy [ __ ] not more of them
please all right all right
what is that I have to drop something
what should I drop how many shots I had
on the sniper
I have to I should probably use okay
I'll drop the shotgun
Oh classroom key you have to go back
I don't want okay
classroom cake classroom on the die-cuts
[ __ ] it
come on bodies bad all of you
No all right I think I already kill them
so it's okay
maybe it's here no no it's not that
oh it's not there well which [ __ ]
classroom is it god damn it
God just [ __ ] damn it there we go
I locked the door back about oh no don't
wait
all right classroom everyone's to get by
in here all right there we go fantastic
break glass but I don't have oh wait
Hamilton all right it's Patong what
I'm so confused I'm sorry taking photos
I'm breaking it there we go
fire exit key oh come on this is just
alright alright we can do this price we
can do aah
hi there that polish I'm so annoying I'm
sorry but after a while it just kind of
gets old on me
alright so foolish bill no you're not a
policeman you are a for this what is
this what is that what is everything oh
I like this Jesse - yeah
all right let's go to the place where we
need to fuse pretty much jump like about
anyone else wanna [ __ ] with me
then the rain no you don't know you
don't you know why I tell you why
because you can't stand aside our samba
side I guess we just have to walk lovely
any monsters in the water wanna know no
one wants to come for me
[Music]
boxing like a bomb all right I don't
know if I know the way I'm just walking
backwards right now
Lucy hope the chainsaw guy isn't there
Dawson Dawson [ __ ] barrel I hate you
in here we should save you problem this
is still there
it's just safe
hello mr. chainsaw guy I love you know I
don't I lied
first Omega all right
bang well my own mouth mouth round
where is it oh now we can get the VPN
awesome let's do it if I only knew where
it was family near oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] so sorry about
saying [ __ ] but you deserved it alright
what is behind this door don't try to
hide stuff from me I bet on you all
night on all night long why get away
I got your friends I will get you - oh
no I wanna why something is blocking I
can see there we go
thank you Jesus penis alright what are
we doing here
alright let's say that I mean why not oh
it's like a shortcut way back I get it
I freaking got it I don't like to sound
out
don't really big fan of this sound yes
here it is isn't it
I didn't know but it's been everyone
well yes it's definitely here oh I mean
that Sal they are not okay don't go to
hit let's go ah don't trip on me now
don't trip on me now boy alright so here
we go setting a few say but anyway I'm
gonna end it here brush like and
favorite to be enjoy subscribe to become
a pro today and I'll see you next
episode and I make alright bench press
enter
am I looking at are you looking at me
more I'll adjust you but you're going
with me cuz I'm alone I will never go
with you payday I will eat your mum's
watch take that back
my mom's pie okay no I never ate my mom